let's do it sounds like you're down a
long hallway ready screaming I'm out how
do we ready
hey sound check
oh my neighbors don't mind me it's mark
the Epis you have tick mark you hit
enter - ready up enter all right
keyboard controls I got the thing right
here I think I'm winning guys I think
I'm winning we have to pick the game
okay hold on
so [ __ ] try hard right now there's
this one there's this one enough mark
our controller it's not working right
now we're on the keyboard team
apparently so all right we're gonna get
totally hos no we'll show them the
master race the pc master race oh hell
no what no just chill out I'm weights
hat hey get on my head hell are we doing
you choose the game myself explode you
guys didn't tell me how to play so I
always wanna know the parkour [ __ ]
now what do you mean [ __ ] color come on
you got a color what's that mean oh I
get it we got to touch that oh okay all
right fine
I'm gonna steal from you Oh son of a
[ __ ] what did I do
we're winning Bob are we winning just
color just color every block you see if
it's flashing you can steal it from the
other team
okay what is
I mean I'm a pro watch touch it just
touch it emoji at this game
your MLG level battleblock theater
should get my abot MLG had I got a pack
so I put that on okay that do ya yes tip
guard oh just get them off okay whatever
you say boss don't ever don't ever get
you know I'm a team but I'm helping you
anyway because I'm a good guy thank wait
only the flashing boys if they're
flashing the ming's they haven't been
committed to the color yet oh okay oh
yeah yeah did we win you don't even know
what you're doing I'm teaching you the
game up in here yeah exactly
have you not seen our drug minecraft you
still got me oh yes right I told you
that we were gonna invite diction to a
drug minecraft but I forgot you mean we
brought captain spirals hop did I get
drunk like that
just a couple times a week okay like all
day - like not even just at nighttime
that's good yeah yeah
no it's perfect especially when I go on
dates and I'm already hammered well that
means you're just cheap we're very
expensive well I don't they don't need
to buy me any drinks that's for sure
okay hey don't you dare make those dream
no no not happening
no siree Bob no siree Bob I think I'm
beating him that's what I'm doing we win
I will steal everything from you this is
my goal right now in life I think we
took advantage of us taking advantage of
diction all right these moving platforms
up every time how do you throw a I'm
good I'm good no no good stupid greenies
what about the Greenies I will do this
again I will do this again I will play
this game it was a fun game head again
cool okay
i'm peacing out thank you
fighting to color anything around very
much at all - throughout I'm just
fighting trying to get packets great bag
up here love me oh god is icier
[ __ ] where the eyes come from I don't
see no eyes it's the icy stuff oh my god
you know the things that are frozen No
oh really tell me miss I know again now
I refuse a my MVP again oh you're not
cutting it Wade or bullet there ain't
before like I have yeah I played
something before I really wish that my
controller would work that's what I wish
different to this this this right is
where you go and you get a you get a pig
and you have to steal the pig all right
well I like that I like pigs pigs are
adorable machine really pissing on the
door I don't Iike pigs door you guys
didn't tell me how to get in a door the
Y button I have a Y button
why do rights other point what do we do
I got sad we need to keep our pig in the
pen I don't know steal their pin go
steal their break and bring it to our
pen what does that mean oh [ __ ] guys
okay over there okay
get off the pig you gotta know if it's
my fig get out of here you're gonna get
lasered ouch oh that's the pig okay
if you jump you get off the pig thing
you know oh my god oh my god oh we got
you off the pig this is the worst thing
that's ever happened to me like that
okay oh [ __ ] wait oh [ __ ] he's got a pig
because I jumped off of it yeah get the
pig Wade come on we gotta make up these
noises you're making noises it's a pig
you're not gonna win I don't think our
intention is to win right now just
playing defense
whatever we'll see who this time yeah
it's us right it's so uh okay
ooh hoo that score hurts I can feel it
on here I mean totally misunderstanding
the mechanics of the game is good too
but Bob does he like me for hitting me
what I had you trapped in the corner Oh
goddamn it sook it's a color one again
what is this boy why you switch the
color ok whatever color wait come on
call everything you weight recovered
let's guard this side like crazy okay we
out side going on over hard this side do
you mean go the other side do that okay
side we ready I love me those are the
blocks over here so you can just kind of
suck it basically I agree I think we
have one - of blocks over here that wimp
Brian percent of the blocks over here so
wait we're doing good I just took that
whole thing that whole row that column
that's mine okay cool lady have this one
I'm like what do you call him Napoleon
didn't conquer stuff no he divided okay
well I'm too
fighting the colors from green to red
cool
enjoy the division bro short enough man
we got hosed non-us games still on
apparently for some reason I need a
jetpack you really yeah you really gotta
get the jet packs in this game mode or
else you're screwed
no oh yeah was it in the walls did I hit
you in the balls I would be the boss hey
I know they're not really over here go
yeah
Wade's doing work over here oh yeah I
think it's trying to help us catch up is
it no system health right okay then
wasted that I wasted dad Keller's no
thank you I'll take the colors give me
this yeah well hey I was the EPI even
when we lost so I don't know what you're
talking about I think we had a jarring
transition from the peg to the colors he
gets like the A for effort ribbon over
there my god more coloring no not this
level this level hey Chuck it's all
ourselves up how do we do that again
just hold the Y button I don't
hold the Y button on your keyboard hold
the button young aggressive gotta kick
it I'm trying to file hey that's weird
we got screwed whatever don't blend the
game blame the hater oh I'm player
hating yo yeah is that what they say on
the streets don't hate me please stop
exploding me stay away from me oh my god
I can only ever kill anyone if I die
with 12 dicks that I've liked from
people that I know personally really
okay ten random dicks yeah that would be
preferable like a PS dozen of dicks
exactly because bakers are good at
counting yes exactly that's exactly
salary to all my Baker fans out there
that we just did you think thirteen is
twelve I feel sorry for you I'm gonna
act like we did even if we didn't all
right oh I think overall you guys won
though because of the thing you know
what's with the orange beets what are we
gonna get the the coveted MVP prize
when you stop sucking the 13 dicks Wow
to be honest they're difficult is there
like a soccer game or anything like an
we gonna know yeah cuz they were in
sequence of one of these lore we start
yeah we gonna start on the left one and
then go over to the right ones okay how
do we go in how do we go in why why I
can't think they're winning in the
ambling they have like limited resources
as far as controls I only know how to
run jump and throw my stupid frisbee
thing I know how to cry for help what do
we do here now oh okay when you die your
soul comes out of your body
oh [ __ ] you gotta grab them grab the
souls of the enemies no these lasers I
swear all right you don't sound sorry
okay I try to get my soul back I got my
soul back oh my god okay please cuz I
got your soul now give me give me the
red haha I got that one Bob no fur good
long time this all's up here
these [ __ ] lasers it's there oh no oh
no wow okay that works
I'm gonna hang out with me okay I'm good
right okay you hold on to the enemy's
sole have your soul they said horses
[Music]
[Laughter]
what what about pig oh wait no you go
over there you grab the pig I'll be over
here watching ours touch my thing no sir
what are you doing no sir what are you
doing what do you know if you
we can't store if our cake is on there
big a bit if I didn't know any better
I'd say if your MVP open that's what
I've done that's good teamwork except
for the me killing art that was whoa
Gold guy I did that grab the gold hello
okay okay
positive you gotta positive okay okay
okay all right depositing it [ __ ] oh I
get it but did I get it
am I kidding oh I'm getting it what God
it's working okay come on deposit into
the big just pretend you go to your
local chase and Walmart where is it oh
yeah thanks
Walmart Bank babe Walmart [ __ ] it's uh
not actually money it's of Walmart cuts
so uh they're not actually real oh god
there's so much money going up laser
boom oh why no Jesus I'm depositing my
cash I don't know gentlemen you mean -
Bob why thank you
how do we hook up oh jeez where's all
this money coming from exactly this
economy doesn't make any sense
yes this is just over inflating the
value of our gold blocks exactly thanks
for all the gold yeah you stay down
there mark I'll just keep beating them
up and really old uh you got it you got
it you got it I'm not going anywhere
hi Bob hi Wade what you doing what you
doing wait no vagina open side up what'd
you do this weekend I believe in us Bob
I thought you're hoping over there
[Music]
that was my whole body there you just
gotta be close to it okay doesn't make
any sense at all
wait didn't even make a deposit yes I
did drawing the whole time button to
deposit here all right okay all control
it was the button that it displayed on
my character to enter the door that was
the board a used to play soccer try to
grab the ball and grab the ball barri
spotty spots opposed to stay on the pigs
oh okay wait how do i ball throw the
ball okay that's cool that's great dude
real mature
no one score I got a ball on my back
what does that mean what the hell
Bob why are you raining Duff that was
dumb
look at the pigs are playing with the
balls on their own man I feel like I was
gonna scar how are they winning are they
waiting from future points and kills now
at this point get away press like B or
something no one job way no here Wade's
got the ball and wait this like a loser
I play goalie how's that going for you
throw the ball how do you throw the ball
Bob go I got your back [ __ ]
[Laughter]
get away from my horsey it's a pig not a
horsey it's a sexy
it's a horsey man I'm shaping the ball
yeah I'm never gonna get MVP yeah you're
cutting in and out so I couldn't hear
what you said but I'm gonna assume you
said good job team they suck was that
what you said that's approximately what
I said yeah cool just just checking that
with all these douchebags
go honey baby do not hide me or point be
don't wait me no boys no more babies
don't leave me baby could you please
stop hurting me babe I need my smokes to
me for nothing happening mark score all
the points I thought I had more dollars
in this but thanks wait for giving me
those I hate you thank you good job Bob
we're winning question mark go to fine
gold I see I see that golden nude engine
oh I got so much gold in me you're now
buddy
you got gold shooting out of your rear
end that's a problem you need to go to a
doctor about that maybe I will maybe
he's a gold doctor you ever think of
that
no I did not
just throwing that out there keep
smacking him keep smacking attract them
who hates it we do we yeah do we follow
do we hate that that's a nice little
frisbee down there but not gonna work
nice it's like a shows that you care
thank you in the money market technique
haha I'm bleeding there for making me
the victor that makes no sense
anybody get my reference was it a
reference was yours different than mine
yours was the foot to face technique and
I did the expanding I'm bleeding did
making me the victor okay yeah so it was
my reference that I initiated I just
want to take the credit for that Bob we
couldn't have a combo reference cuz
we're on the same team no I'm saying I
came up with it and then you tried to
jump on the credit train I thought we
were like together on all king of the
hill okay I got a they'll come on wait I
believe in you do you the probably
shouldn't don't push me wait I'm on your
team we got this Marco I'm trying get
off my block no how do you like that
like that uppercut uppercut [ __ ]
alright I'm secret trick wait you're
using a controller right yeah you next
to impress the right trigger and you'll
toss them
all right Julie got a cry for help right
handle my sorry buddy how do we how do
we throw I don't know help you now we
are the kings of this Hill right now
sorry Bob how do I throw a frisbee Bob
mom what would you say I said oh come on
come on we can't knock you off ill for
that yeah how do we let you off the hill
we didn't know you just push push
punching it wasn't working well I'm not
sure about that Wade take a look at the
big scoreboard thing that we were all
looking at because there's someone in
first place for I'm gonna get the
controls really quick I don't even think
we need the controls Bob because palms
are sweaty mom's sphaghetti knees weak
arms heavy spaghetti mom's party I know
that if I get ready to drop mom's
spaghetti
oh those are lazy why did I activate
those what are we doing it oh it's the
sole ground
Oh teleporting cool yeah Oh God how do
they have both our souls already come on
okay there we go gotcha
no you don't what the hell I hit you
don't ask me oh whoa whoa what is going
on there this is a monstrosity what
particular Lee do what the tically do
was I'm just gonna make up words I don't
care anymore
yeah bye I'll take that bob-dog you're
sorry back okay I would love to support
not die immediately Bobby ever sold oh
come on okay but you got it Oh oh my god
are you serious yeah maybe you wanna
fight about it this this purple juice I
hate I hate this oh my god oh god help
me to another land out of here Oh God
wait okay I'm not one of their souls I
got some mono teleport there what
teleporter do I need what do you don't
even hit me and I die how is this where
we go finally goddamn did this video are
your jimmies Russell
Russell my jimmies what button do i
press ok let's go
[Laughter]
okay alright okay I gotta push two
buttons at once Tyler like the wind can
you see the colors of the rainbow on my
skin do you feel the wolf job in the
morning when you go to take this job you
don't know what about wolf do is it like
a blow job but from a wolf that sounds
by Barry put up a graphic a wolf job
Barry how various berries seems to be
gone Barry candy have a very tired
you fired son Barry if you could with
the soccer ball there just to confuse us
Wow okay wait can't put it in the basket
so I think it's okay thank you yeah
thank you I know it was whoops
Jabar insult I got it I did it
Bob I did it I scored did you see Bob
Bob I scored I scored my map back with
the stupid coloring was I know wasn't
what happened there
nice nice even numbers 222 to 160 I like
the world did that game even work what
the hell happened there I don't mob we
just have to win one more game and we
win overall I think what is this just
fighting points what foul this is just
from hitting people how I killed myself
they got points for that B don't kill me
my man oh I got stuck on that oh no
you're not gonna frisk me if I might
frisbee you to life oh God
how about you think about that what just
jumping on that no no one told me that
was acid Oh God dang it
yeah that was that was classy hype unch
the disk thing in midair into you
somehow yeah that acid there right yeah
that Dad acid
I'm gonna get to eventually we're
creaming them I need to cream like an
ice cream corn oh my god those totally
intentional and totally skilled enemies
Bob we got to win this next one so that
we can win it overall it's all tied up I
think no no no will be tied after this
one and then we'll need to go
we'll need a word yeah see it's all tied
up it comes down to this oh we know we
read a whole nother session Bob the
difference is they actually care if they
win you don't know that yeah well it's
whoever wins gets a hundred thousand
subscribers so I mean there's a lot of
stake here O'Shea really yeah yeah true
enough Bob yeah you're the best Bob yeah
Bob Bob Bob Bob sorry sorry Bob I got
this I got it Bob yay Bob Bob Bob Bob
Bob Bob sorry on your way let's try that
again Bob don't you hit me in the nose
[Music]
ba-ba-ba-ba-ba bounce me a bow oh thank
you
whoops sorry he's got it he's doing some
[Applause]
[Music]
weight oh he got smart good yes so good
there do that every time can we do that
never heard that word really well yeah I
like that
good good job did you score you didn't
score bow okay god we freaking suck at
this one yeah I don't remember how to
play I'll go for the baskets
maybe oh no he's going for the basket
okay that's okay then I don't think my
way sorry Bob
[Music]
what are you doing maybe score it no
like that
bye stick your points yeah god dammit if
I give if I score like that it'll give
me more points let them score
wait don't bother them
stay out here stand here oh wait he's
okay Betty mom they're just trying to
get your headband all right get off
[ __ ] hang on my [ __ ] way baba wait
wait
Bob hold on there but I'm working on it
Bob yeah I got it we okay bye Bob
I'm tired of this Bob chapter you keep
talking to score let's go
that's off me that's off me okay you
guys have fun over there wait you can't
do it without someone over there -
doubts office huh just fine thank you
very much now you didn't you bounced up
my head no I scored like three times
while you were gone now you know wire
you're lying for your sister but wait
wait it's like this but wait wait hang
on wait let me show you how stuck wait
wait wait come on wait wait now wait
baby wait baby see I scored like this
like this cheating ways you mean
shooting up like a basketball the
cheating way I press up and shoot it is
now you no no it's a keyboard thing you
need a keyboard to do that I'm sorry
press the B button the D button and you
don't have that I do too it's called the
back button no no it's not Mac stands
for D I know this I'm a scientist yeah
but you have a controller adapter that's
just a giant penis game-type whoa whoa
oh my god there's a cannon wait wait
okay don't don't do that don't go near
the cannon the cannons a dick hey Bob
you know what if we even if we lose we
still win so you're gonna unless we do
one more to even it out no this was
that's always high really hard - yes
sorry mark yes thank you thank you for
getting me in the way of that cannon
blast her welcome not you I was talking
to my teammates actually me that we're
totally winning this right now yeah I
just battle just battled with their
cannons there is a cannon on the cannon
[Laughter]
we have so much lead right now and
nowhere else pretty good spot for you
you should probably move it's really bad
you don't wanna be are you okay see see
what I mean the cannon really is gonna
get you seriously
it's that whole time yeah Bob and I had
a great time were you talking about
you kids suck it it's okay hey I bet one
of you is gonna get the MVP I really do
I really hope you do I don't make the
rules
I'll make the rules I never played the
game before oh good game everybody go
baby go everyone be a half
good game everybody good game good GG
dude GG gg good gg ok what dick dick
should be a hat on me and then let me
see what happens when I got a goal
you guys want to do any outros or are
you guys good thank you all so much for
watching until next time may the force
be with you
real astronauts half-assed like that
very fast I think that's just farting
and exploding is pretty good out no you
can be farting and exploding I'm just
gonna be over here doing a real outro
ready it's gonna be great ok thank you
everybody so much for watching
it's been a pleasure to have you here
with us today thank you eat my addiction
1 my skirm and lord minion 777 Ferb
being here with me to lose except for
you Bob cuz you're awesome
thanks again everybody for watching if
you enjoyed this and want to see more
please leave a like down below and as
always we will see you in this video
[Music]
I twisted the damage over time I do